قوارب غارقه وسفن حربيه قديمه وبقايا
بشريه كلها بدات منذ سنوات تظهر في مياه
بحيره ميد الامريكيه
تلك البحيرات التي تتشكل خلف سد هوفر
الشهير بين ولايتين فادا واريزونا وتعد
خزانا حيويا للبلاد انه زمن الجفاف 17
ضعفا لهذا الخزان هو حجم المياه التي جفت
في العالم مجله ساينس القت الضوء على اكبر
كارثه مائيه يعيشها الكوكب
اكثر من 50% من بحيرات العالم تقلصت
مساحتها بفعل الجفاف خلال العقود ثلاثه
الماضيه وذلك امتدادا من بحر قزوين بين
اوروبا واسيا الى بحيره تيتيكاكا في
امريكا الجنوبيه بحسب مجله ساينس العلميه
تزايد درجات الحراره له النصيب الاكبر من
اسباب تفاقم الظاهره
فمع الاحتباس الحراري هناك ايضا الاستهلاك
البشري وبناء السدود وتراجع معدلات
الامطار بين الاسباب خلف الظاهره المقلقه
صور تقلص المساحات المائيه تحبس الانفاس
25% من سكان العالم يعيشون في مناطق تعاني
بحيراتها من الجفاف او تتبخر المياه في
سدودها ولكن كالعاده الفقراء هم الاكثر
تضررا ودول الناميه هي الاضعف جهزيه
لمواجهه الاثار المدمره مياه تفقد
صلاحيتها للشرب انواع النباتيه وحيوانيه
تختفي والصحه المهدده لدى البشر هكذا
يواجه الانسان زمن الجفاف ذلك الانسان
الذي عايش العصور الجليديه وها هو يواجه
زمن التغير المناخي وحديه المتناقضين
غرقوا الارض
وجفاف المياه
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات